how can I go from somebody who is
constantly on that and overusing let's
say a smartphone to somebody who uses it
more intelligently well so the basic
idea behind my digital minimalist
prescription is wipe the slate clean
take everything off that you don't
absolutely need professionally or to get
to your day-to-day life any sort of
optional technology step away for 30
days completely completely that this is
social media this is online news this is
streaming media saw the fear in my
business video it is scary but just like
when you declutter a closet you take
everything out then figure out what I
want to put back I think you should do
the same with your digital life you
really do feel like to me that you are
the Marie Kondo
right now of Technology yes yes I mean
it's a similar idea now ironically I
didn't know much about Marie Kondo until
after I wrote this book but she's
preaching metabolism as well right so
this is minimalism in your physical
possessions I'm talking about minimalism
with your digital possessions that's the
same idea all those apps that you
randomly downloaded all the services you
signed up for out of web take it all out
of the proverbial closet step back get
back in touch with how you actually want
to spend your time and then very
carefully begin reintroduce heed only
the things that are going to give you
that big benefit what are the easiest
things you can do is you know take off
your phone any app where someone makes
money every time you tap on it that
alone it's going to give you a lot of
your life back I'm not saying you have
to quit these services right off the bat
you're welcome to sign on to say social
media platforms using your desktop
computer but not having it with you
bead free from the sort of digital slot
machine that exists in your pocket that
change a load is going to have dramatic
benefits your life